hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español en esta oportunidad
nos acompaña andrés fernando suárez el
sociólogo máster en estudios políticos y
también escritor todo un referente para
conocer de cerca el conflicto armado
colombiano y también la violencia que lo
atraviesa es autor del libro el silencio
del horror guerra y masacres en colombia
un libro que acaba de ser publicado y en
el que describe y analiza lo que nos
revelan las masacres perpetradas en el
marco del conflicto armado colombiano
sus variaciones sus características los
actores involucrados entre muchos otros
factores andrés fernando suárez
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
santiago clasificación bueno comencemos
por lo que caracteriza no hay diferencia
a una masacre de otros actos de
violencia extrema que incluso muchas
veces son definidos no también como
masacres un elemento clave sobre el que
hacer referencia en el libro que tengo
en mis manos precisamente es la relación
asimétrica no que existe entre el actor
de la población civil y la indefensión
de las víctimas o sea que se puede matar
masivamente en un conflicto armado sin
perpetrar una masacre verdad
así de santiago una masa que tiene cinco
características esenciales es un
homicidio intencional
se dirigen contra la popa contra
personas en estado de indefensión
ocurre en unas mismas circunstancias de
modo tiempo y lugar y tiene esta
característica distintiva es una
relación en la que hay un actor armado y
una población totalmente indefensa es el
encuentro entre la impotencia total y la
prepotencia total del actor armado
entonces tiene razón efectivamente en la
guerra puede morir masivamente muchas
personas incluso indefensas pero no
constituir una masa por ejemplo en las
acciones bélicas podría jugar ese tipo
de eventos o en los atentados
terroristas la masaje tiene esa
particularidad y una relación presencia
entre los entre el actor que perpetra el
evento y las víctimas de la pared ahora
digamos también algo que planteas en el
libro es que la masacre hay alguien la
masacre una puesta en escena verdad es
ante todo y voy a citar te un
espectáculo del horror tiene una
dimensión comunicativa verdad se exhibe
se muestra no se oculta en absoluto
siguiendo esta línea como marca una
sociedad y su memoria colectiva
si la masacre es un acto comunicativo
muy poderoso que se produce para
intimidar para aterrorizar es una llama
de guerra para ganar ventaja sobre el
enemigo
e influir sobre la sociedad como fue en
las masacres marcar a las sociedades
cuando una masacre ocurre la frontera
moral de las sociedades frente a lo que
tolera en cuanto a la violencia se va
moviendo se va moviendo los actores
armados recurren a este método probando
todo el tiempo hasta dónde es capaz la
sociedad de aguantar entonces lo que
esto dice de las sociedades es muy muy
interesante muy importante porque cada
vez que ocurren masacres y la sociedad
no reacciona los actores armados tienen
licencia para seguirlas perpetrando
porque saben que un límite moral va
cambiando las masacres nos cambian la
moralidad les vamos a vivir para una
nueva moralidad y mucho más si ésta se
va repitiendo y repitiendo y como
sociedad no reaccionamos
una de las premisas fundamentales de su
libro es que no se pueden comprender las
masacres aisladas del conflicto armado
en colombia no se inscriben en toda una
trama de violencia como fueron cambiando
andrés las características de la masacre
junto a los cambios en lo que ha sido y
es el conflicto armado colombiano que
continuidad es y qué transformaciones se
encuentra
[Música]
si las masacres elegí el período 1981 a
2021 40 años de conflicto armado porque
es a partir de 1981 que irrumpen las
masacres nuevamente en los repertorios
de violencia de los actores armados y es
ahí cuando el conflicto armado
colombiano despega
es decir la masacre está en el corazón
del escalamiento del conflicto armado
por eso cada vez que ocurren masacres
estamos ante una señal de alerta de un
posible recrudecimiento del conflicto
armado ellas aparecen cuando otras
modalidades de violencia han empezado a
escalar a presentarse recrudecerse por
lo que dije anteriormente porque van
moviendo la frontera moral no van
convirtiéndose en espectáculos de horror
que nos dicen nos mueve en el límite de
la violencia tolerable y
esa es la esencia de la guerra la
violencia es el lenguaje de la guerra y
la masacre es una de sus mayores
expresiones le muestra a la sociedad y
al otro contra que combato estoy
dispuesto a todo que no hay límites
que la violencia va a ser más extensiva
más dolorosa más transgresora si usted
no se rinde no o si usted está dispuesto
a prolongar la guerra ese es el precio
que va a pagar
además andrés en este contexto de los
responsables no usted tiene datos muy
exhaustivos en su libro aquí en colombia
entre los principales se encuentran los
paramilitares no luego las guerrillas y
también agentes del estado de que nos
habla esto de que nos dice sobre todo le
quiero preguntar de lo que diferencian
hoy caracterizan a las masacres
colombiana a diferencia de otras de
américa latina como por ejemplo las de
guatemala o perú a las que usted mismo
hace referencia en su libro
si tenemos una diferencia muy importante
en cuanto a las responsabilidades las
masacres colombianas no tienen una
participación directa en una alta
proporción de agentes de estado lo que
no quiere decir que no haya
responsabilidades por omisión o por
complicidad con el principal perpetrador
de las masajes que son los grupos
paramilitares es una diferencia muy
importante que hay con otros contextos y
otra diferencia que quiero resaltar
mucho es que uno pensaría que cuando las
masacres ocurren los actores armados van
a ser lo mismo todos y resulta que no en
las masacres guerrilleras son distintas
de las masacres que perpetran los
paramilitares e incluso que las que
perpetran los agentes de estado también
tenemos una particularidad de nuestras
masacres y es
el nivel de servicio que se exhibe en
nuestras masajes es decir de
mutilaciones de los cuerpos ese tipo de
prácticas de tortura física sobre el
cuerpo no es si nos registran los mismos
niveles que en otros países y en estos
otros contextos otra diferencia es el el
tamaño de las masas las dimensiones de
las masajes en colombia son masacres más
pequeñas y eso es lo que la hace más
amenazante en el caso colombiano son
muchas masacres con menos víctimas
aparecen seguramente todos los días en
los medios de comunicación pero no son
el gran evento del evento disruptivo el
evento que viene alterarlo todo va a
cambiarlo todo y ese es ese efecto
erosivo esa que nos va moviendo
lentamente esa frontera moral de la que
hablo esa nueva moralidad que vamos
teniendo en esos otros contextos
ocurrían muy concentradas en el tiempo
con grandes dimensiones y eso creo que
en parte también esperan esos conflictos
se han resuelto más rápido
porque el límite el umbral de violencia
que la sociedad podría tolerar no las
partes terminó decantándose más rápido
en cambio aquí se ha incorporado para
equiparnos para una guerra de larga
duración hablemos ahora de otro tema muy
importante que usted también aborda en
el libro y es qué construcción hay de la
víctima no cómo es percibida usted de
hecho cita autores que plantean algo que
fue interesante porque quizás uno
creería que hay una cierta
deshumanización verdad de la víctima
pero no obstante ellos señalan que por
el contrario ese carácter humano es
precisamente el que anima la sed de
sangre verdad que en muchos casos
estimula estas atrocidades
así de santiago en la víctima que en
nuestro análisis la vemos en la masacre
como una persona indefensa no es
percibida así por el actor armado está
perpetrando la masacre eso qué quiere
decir que hay un entrenamiento muy
profundo de los actores armados para
poder perpetrar estas atrocidades porque
ellos aquí en vena y es a un enemigo
obstruyen a la víctima como un enemigo
no le quitan rasgos humanos se los
resaltan y aprovechan la indefensión
para decir ahora tengo al enemigo donde
lo quiero tener hay un trabajo de
entrenamiento de formación de los
combatientes muy profundo diciéndole
usted no puede tener empatía con esa
persona porque esa persona que usted ve
ahora indefensa más adelante puede
perpetrar sobre usted la violencia y las
atrocidades miren que los actores
armados tienen un gran desprecio por la
población civil nosotros diríamos deben
respetarla porque están en estado de
indefensión no participan en la guerra
en a diferencia de eso
tienen un gran desprecio con la
población civil porque piensan que la
población civil es muy importante en las
estrategias de guerra los apoyos que
ellas le dan o le quitan a un actor
armado son definitivos para embalarse
final que vaya a tener la guerra yo
dicen un civil que le da información al
otro grupo armado es más peligroso que
alguien en armas y entonces todos estos
sentimientos todas esas emociones todas
esas representaciones son explotadas en
el combatiente que va a perpetrar la
masacre para que no sienta culpa por lo
que está haciendo usted está matando
enemigos no se deje distraer por la
apariencia o los rostros que ellos
tienen andrés y qué ocurrió tras la
firma de los acuerdos de paz con la ex
guerrilla de las farc
bueno veníamos de un período de
crecimiento generalizado y las masacres
desde el 2005 en adelante se escaló de
una manera muy importante el número de
masacres pero lamentablemente a partir
del 2017 justo después de la firma del
acuerdo empezamos a tener un
escalamiento de las masacres
2018 o 2017 y 2018 estuvieron cifras
y que aún no eran tan preocupantes pero
el año 2020 es un año terrible porque
fue un año que nos puso en niveles de
masacres iguales a los que habían antes
de iniciar el proceso de paz o sea en
2008 lo que es muy grave no términos de
lo que significa el contexto para la
implementación del acuerdo de paz pero
segundo nótese algo que es muy
importante las masacres llegan al pico a
este pico de escalamiento después de que
hemos tenido unos fenómenos de
escalamiento asesinato de líderes
sociales de combatientes y las masacres
aparecen después de ese escalamiento
por eso yo insisto la masacre es una
forma de ir moviendo la frontera moral
de la sociedad y si la sociedad no
reacciona
el problema es que vamos a entrar en una
etapa de recrudecimiento en conflicto
esta transición cada vez se parece más
la transición a una nueva forma de
guerra
andrés fernando suárez muchísimas
gracias por este paso por france24 ha
sido realmente muy interesante el
diálogo con usted
santiago muchas gracias no gracias a
usted una vez más en nuestra audiencia
como siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto con gracias por
acompañarnos y sigan junto a nosotros